welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm paul aka the host with about as much
personality as michael myers
and in this video we're breaking down
fierce street part 1 1994.
the first chapter in the netflix trilogy
has a lot to unpack from it
and over the next three weeks we'll be
going through the ins and outs of the
film saga
now the series is based on the book of
the same name from rl stein
who you might know from making your crap
your pants as a kid with his goosebumps
series
stein was very much the stephen king of
my middle school library
and growing up i think i must have had
over 40 of his books
he's the person that really got me
interested in the horror genre
so naturally when i heard fierce street
was being made into a netflix trilogy
i couldn't wait to sink my thanks into
it now the film itself is based heavily
on the slasher genre
and in it there are nods to halloween
friday the 13th
and of course scream which was released
in 1996.
that movie opened with the murder of
drew barrymore which came as a big shock
to everyone
as she was a very established actor at
the time this idea of killing off a name
in the early part of a film
was actually playing on psycho and
fierce street has its own homage to that
in the introduction of the film we watch
as a mole worker is murdered
and she's played by none other than maya
hawk maya he
my haha now the killer themselves wears
a skull mask
and it's clear they're playing tribute
to that classic 90s film
there's also notes to other horror
properties from the decade at least i
think there is as the two towns we focus
on are shadyside and sunnyvale
which i think might be a nod to
sunnydale the town that buffy the
vampire slayer was set in
now that might be a reach and this might
not be the best time to ask for a like
but if you don't then tonight at
midnight when you're in bed
you'll look up and see me above you and
i'll spoil the ending of no way home
the subscribe button's there too whilst
you're at it now this movie is very
fourth wall breaking
and it opens with maya's character
heather sticking her fingers up to a
customer at the mall that calls a book
she loved
lowbrow horror rl is really sticking his
fingers up here to people who didn't
like the haunted mask
what's wrong with you it's a classic and
there's also books by robert lawrence
which
no prize is for guessing is what rl
stands for
this most notably appears on one title
fear street
which they did it now sunnyvale's team
are also called the devils
and the number 666 appears throughout
the film we can see that heather's
killer ryan was fine moments before he
went on his murder spree
but a mysterious flyer landed on his
neck and clearly
this changed his demeanor flies are
often known to be vessels of witches and
this is why
cicada showed up in one division maya
was of course killed and
ryan was shot dead by the local sheriff
nick good
good shot bad timing these videos are
terrible now strangely killings like
this have been going on in shadyside for
hundreds of years
reoccurring every couple of decades and
this dates back all the way to 1666
which
no price is for guessing has 666 in it
we know that part 3 will be set during
this year
with 1978 being the next stop so clearly
we're gonna learn all the ins and outs
of what has plagued this town for
centuries
we discover that at the core of the
curse is a witch named sarah fier
who the settlers of shadyside hanged in
1666
for practicing witchcraft sarah cast a
spell on the town that's allowed her to
possess people
in order to wreak havoc and kill the
descendants of those that hanged her
we get lip service to other killers such
as a pastor named cyrus miller
who murdered children in there was a man
that killed girls in 1904
one in 1922 as well as an axe murderer
that killed several teens at camp
nightwing in 1978.
this is the setting for the next film
and it's clearly pulling from the first
friday the 13th movie
now after the title sequence we pick up
with dina a high school student that
recently broke up with her girlfriend
sam
sam moved to the neighboring peaceful
town of sunnyvale which has a rivalry
with shadyside
this kind of spills over into the main
plot when the football teams end up
fighting at a vigil for the victims
they chase the shadysiders out of town
and dina almost ends up throwing a
bucket of ice onto their car
however after her nose starts to bleed
she drops the entire thing
causing those from sunnyvale to crash
into a tree
this was clearly the work of the witch
and sam climbs out of the car
seeing a vision of her after touching
the ground sam is taken to hospital
and slowly stranger things start to
happen with a mysterious
skull mask wearing character stalking
the cast
we discover that dina and her group of
friends have all seen the same figure
and at one point dina unmasks him to see
that it's ryan who of course died at the
start of the movie
more long dead thought killers arrive
and we realize that they can't be
stopped
spoken to or bargained with these
relentless killing machines are
invincible
and they start to hunt the group through
josh we discover the truth about the
killers and learn that sam is actually
the only target of sarah
it's revealed that after the accident
she ended up touching the witch's bones
as they lay in the dirt
and this is what set off the curse once
more now the group race against time to
find out how to stop the killers
and along the way the killers get the
group of friends one by one
up until probably the last 40 minutes i
thought the movie was pretty tame
but they really take the cake with some
of the killings thank you i'm here all
week now they realize that the only way
to save sam
is to kill her and then when the
murderers are gone bring her back to
life
this works and when sam dies the
murderers disappear
allowing for dina to resuscitate the
character they lie to the police and say
that there wasn't anything supernatural
and poor kate and simon end up taking
the blame and the movie ends strangely
with dina getting a call from a woman
who we learn was the sole survivor of
camp nightwing
she tells her that it's not over and
warns that the witch will still be after
her
we get this confirmed when we catch a
witch in a coven carrying out a spell
which engraves sam's name into stone
just below ryan's
much like ryan became possessed sam does
too
and she stabs dina now luckily this
doesn't kill the character
and she manages to tie sam up with a
telephone cord
both dina and josh go to visit the sole
survivor c berman
who we see is played by jillian jacobs
from community
we then get some flashbacks to the camp
and what happened there
now though we know c died and that this
lifted the curse
we still don't know exactly how she came
to survive the entire ordeal for several
decades
clearly there is something else afoot
here and dina promises that she will
free sam of her possession
now the next entry like we mentioned is
clearly pulling from friday the 13th
and i have a feeling that a twist might
be that c is actually part of the
possessed herself
hell she may even be the one carrying
out the rituals that we saw to keep the
curse going
and this would explain why she was
spared in the first place it just seems
weird that the curse suddenly stopped
yet continued with the others when they
followed the same steps
i think that going forward there could
be a big reveal
there's also that strange person on
instant messenger that josh is talking
to
i believe that this could also be c as
well hell
everyone see if you ask me as that's the
only character
we don't really know that much about i
also think that somehow the characters
may end up traveling back to 1978
and also 1666 in order to perhaps
learn things about the past i think
that's way better than simply seeing
things from another's perspective
and there's really no way for us to
connect with a character from the latter
year as
they'd be long dead by now either way
though we won't have to wait much longer
and next friday we'll see the release of
part two which i will no doubt be
covering
i had a lot of fun with his first entry
and i'm excited to see where the trilogy
goes
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the first part so make sure
you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of july
in which we pick three random comments
so you can win an mcu box set of your
choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on part one the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of loki which will be linked
on screen right now
we've gone over the latest episode from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i'll be ball and i'll
see you next time
take care peace
you